-My first guest is
an Oscar-winning icon
who is now guest-starring in
the fourth season of
"Search Party" on HBO Max.
The final four episodes
of Season 4
begin streaming this Thursday.
Here she is, Susan Sarandon.
Oh! This is --
Susan, I -- I'm honored.
-Welcome.
-I'm so honored to be
welcomed into your home.
This is amazing.
-Yes, I have not let anyone
film in my house,
even Barbara Walters,
when she wanted to.
Oprah, no.
-Yeah.
-And now here you are.
-Unbelievable.
-You're a little, tiny piece
of my New York apartment.
-Oh, I'm so happy.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, we just started --
Well, we came back
to the studio to do these shows
here with, like,
remote cameras
and stuff like that,
and so there's no family here.
There's no kids running around.
-Yeah, they've been
torturing you.
I think people have developed
such an appreciation of
teachers and moms
that work at home
and without alcohol or drugs.
It's a big deal. Yeah.
-It really, really is.
Franny just lost her
second tooth yesterday,
right here.
-Did they come out naturally
or did you take it out?
-She pulled it out.
It came out naturally.
-My granddaughter --
My eldest granddaughter's father
is an ex-soccer pro,
Kyle Martino.
So, her tooth was wiggling,
and she was at his house
in Brooklyn.
And he taped a string
to a soccer ball.
He taped floss to a soccer ball,
put it around her tooth,
and kicked it.
And it worked, but then guess
what the downside of that is.
Where's the tooth?
-Yeah, the tooth is gone.
-Yeah, you can't find the tooth.
So, the second one,
they did a better job,
and she kicked
the ball herself,
and they managed to
keep an eye on the tooth.
But it started
a whole tradition.
that I think only
a soccer pro -- footballer --
would think to do.
-I'm always happy to see you,
and I actually have been
seeing you recently
pop up online
with these paparazzi shots.
I don't know if you know what
I'm talking about.
You're walking -- You take walks
with Jessica Lange,
apparently,
around New York City.
Oh, there it is.
We have a photo.
That's you and Jessica Lange.
And then there's photos of you,
like, helping people,
like, helping people
cross the street
and all these nice,
Good Samaritan things.
And people are saying online
that they think that
you guys are superheroes.
-We are.
But, you know,
look at what it --
Look at what that tells you
about the paparazzi.
How desperate are they that
they're following
two bundled-up people -- you
can't even tell who we are --
for an hour and a half in
Lower Manhattan,
just hoping something's
going to happen?
And, so, Jess and I were saying,
"Maybe this time when we go out,
we're going to have to
find, like, a burning building
or someone down a manhole."
-Yeah. I'll stage something
with you guys if you want me to.
-Yeah. I know.
That was really -- That's a lot.
That's a lot.
-Oh, you know what
I want to ask you?
Because everyone's at home,
and they're watching
all these movies
and their favorite movies.
And "Thelma & Louise"
has had a total resurgence.
Everyone's like --
New generations are watching it,
talking about it.
-Oh, good.
-Yeah.
People dressing up as you guys.
-I didn't know that.
That's cool.
-Obviously, the ending of the
film -- I can't spoil it now --
but when you -- Did you ever go
to Grand Canyon at all?
And if you ever do,
do people go, like --
Do they get excited or do they
go, "How'd you get here?"
-Years ago,
I did have a really great --
Well, someone had
a really great moment,
because I was with
my youngest son.
We were doing a trip around
and we were in
the Grand Canyon briefly.
And we went into the gift shop,
and there were two women
who were doing a
"Thelma & Louise" trip.
And there I was welcoming them,
making an extra 25 cents
to push my movie.
-See? Yeah,
that's how hard you work.
-They talked about a sequel,
but I could not --
I don't know what it would be.
I can't understand.
-No, it would be like --
Do you remember the movie --
Was it "Topper"?
Do you remember that movie?
-Oh, yeah.
Actually, that was
a very bad idea they had,
of we were ghosts
looking down on Earth
and helping women who were in
domestic -- bad dome-- Yeah.
And I said --
I remember saying to Tim,
"But what would we be doing?"
And he said,
"You'd be getting a big check."
-[ Laughs ]
That's a good line, at least.
-No, that didn't work out.
-Best to leave it alone.
-Oh, you know, I heard a fun
story about you and Geena Davis.
Is this true that, one time,
she dressed up as a bear
and, like, scared your kids
at a camp-out?
-We were having --
I was throwing my daughter
a camping party
in our living room,
and so they were going to do
hot dogs on the fire
and they were -- I got,
you know, cassettes of
animal noises.
And they were sleeping
right in the living room.
And we had the bear suit,
of course.
We provided the bear suit.
But Geena, very nicely,
did a very good job of
wearing that bear suit.
And she did briefly,
but she's not --
You know, for somebody
who is formidable,
she's not very scary, actually.
-She's not, but, yeah,
in a bear suit, though.
-She couldn't really -- She just
revealed herself way soon.
-And just started laughing.
I want to talk to you about
"Search Party."
What can we say
about "Search party"? And --
-So many funny things.
So out of the box.
So -- All of these kids that
are in it are so good.
I'm kind of playing
the plot twist,
so you'll see -- You didn't
even see where it goes.
And I had so much fun.
And you can
tell, when you watch it,
that everybody that's on it
is having so much fun.
But, at the same time,
Cole Escola
makes an appearance now
in a big part in this season,
and they get really scary.
-It's brilliant.
-Well, it was a job that,
actually, my son got me.
It's nepotism,
because he knows Charles,
and so he said, "Mom,
I think they're interested,
and would you like to?"
And so I really --
Now I start getting jobs
because of my children.
-See? It comes full circle.
-And, also, "Motherlover"
was like that,
because my youngest was like,
"Mom, you have to do it."
I didn't know what
"Dick in a Box" was.
And he was like,
"It's a classic.
Whatever they ask you to do,
you have to do it.
Absolutely."
So I did it.
-That ends up happening, right?
Your kids end up going like,
"No, mom, dad, this is cool.
That's not cool. Do this thing."
-Yeah.
-And you're like, "Okay."
Yeah, already,
I'm trying to please my kids,
and that's why
I'm not going to host
"The Tonight Show" anymore.
I'm the now voice of Peppa Pig.
-It will pay off later.
It will pay off later.
Right now, not so much.
Right now,
you're in the trenches.
But it eventually --
It pays off.
-Alright, good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Susan Sarandon in
Season 4 of "Search Party."
Take a look at this.
-Call baby brother.
[ Ringtone ]
-Hello?
-Richard.
I made it to Babyfoot
and I'm in the house.
Uh, chip is not.
The situation
has turned sour, though.
Uh, there's a dead body.
-Oh. The Dory girl?
-Oh. Uh...
No, I don't think
it is the Dory girl.
This woman is old.
Provincial.
Oh, and there's
a room full of chains.
Uh, I don't remember them being
there when we bought the house.
-Susan Sarandon.
Check out
the final four episodes of
Season 4 of "Search Party" this
Thursday on HBO Max.